I have three short stories for you today to
kick off this uh, Friday like Wednesday show
because of the thanks
is giving holiday starting with Fox news host
Tucker Carlson, who strangely set on his program
that he's rooting for Russia in the conflict
with Ukraine. What exactly that means? We
don't know. Saying both that he was serious
and later on in the show that he was joking.
I guess he's covering all bases no matter
who sees the video. It was a joke and it's
serious. Take a look.
So a hundred Biden didn't I know a hundred
Biden. I actually liked Hunter Biden, but
that's totally corrupt and you know it. Why
is it worse to ask about it than it is to
do it? Because people are dying on the front
lines. You think it's a joke going on in the
conflict between Ukraine and Russia. I'm serious.
I don't care why and why shouldn't I root
for Russia, which I am because those of us
who are watching myself who think democracy,
preserving democracy is important. When Dick
Cheney said what the Russians did was an attack.
I don't care more like attack on the U S and
I think if Donald Trump gets off the hook
on this, he's going to put the arm on the
Chinese and everybody,
okay, so there he says he's rooting for Russia.
Then later in the show, clearly Tucker Carlson
tipped off that maybe it wasn't the wisest
thing to say that you're rooting for Russia
against Ukraine, a historical ally of the
United States. So then he did the, it was
a joke thing. I'm really rooting for the United
States.
Trace Gallagher, the great Chris Gallagher.
Thank you. Write a time right before we go.
Earlier in the show, I noted that I was rooting
for Russia in the contest between Russia and
Ukraine. And of course I'm joking, I'm only
rooting for America.
So is this the biggest deal in the grand scheme
of things for Tucker Carlson? Not really.
He said, immigrants make our country dirty.
He said white supremacy is a hoax. He said
the other things. So in the grand scheme of
things, this pales in comparison. It is interesting
though that he clarifies. I'm actually rooting
for the United States, of course with the
uh, historical Alliance of the United States
and Ukraine. You would imagine that that would
not equate to, uh, supporting Russia against
Ukraine. Just a very strange thing in general
for Tucker Carlson to say and very interestingly,
this next story is a very, very serious, very
good series of clips. Tucker Carlson was called
out on Fox news by a guest and it was extraordinarily
worth watching, particularly because of how
the host interviewing the person calling out
Tucker got visibly upset. Let's
go
to that next.